the president also said Saudi Arabia's
government deserves severe punishment if
it killed Washington Post contributor
Jamal Khashoggi the Saudi born
journalist vanished after entering the
Saudi consulate in Istanbul Turkey that
was nearly two weeks ago now the Saudis
deny harming him and threatened now to
retaliate if any sanctions are imposed
over the incident president Trump told
60 minutes the US will find out what
happened tell everybody what's at stake
here
you know this is a lot of shake there's
a lot at stake and maybe especially so
because this man was a reporter there's
something you'll be surprised to hear me
say that is something really terrible
and disgusting about that if that were
the case so we're gonna have to see
we're going to get to the bottom of it
and there will be severe punishment CBS
News senior national security
contributor Michael Morell is a former
acting director and deputy director of
the CIA Michael good morning let's start
with the president saying that the u.s.
is gonna get to the bottom of this
there's been talk of recordings how does
the u.s. get to the bottom of this John
I think we need a couple of things one
is we need the Turks to share with us
whatever information they have I believe
that they had intelligence sources
inside that consulate I believe that's
where the recordings come from they need
to share those with us and they need to
share that soon the Saudis need to share
with us what they have and then we need
to collect our own intelligence so that
we can corroborate whatever the Turks
and Saudis are telling us it's only when
we have all of that information that the
intelligence community will be able to
tell the president with any sort of
confidence what we think happened inside
that consulate which is still murky
because there's two narratives and
there's two competing narratives so has
there been a rush to judgment
I think the Turkish narrative is more
compelling because they say they have
evidence and there's the the Saudis have
done no explanation so I think that is
more compelling and that's where most
people have gone but but the bottom line
nor is that we still don't know what
happened inside that council let's deal
with the news this morning as you hear
that Turkey and Saudi Arabia are
expected to conduct a join
inspection on Monday is that significant
I think it's significant that they're
working together but I wouldn't expect a
whole heck of a lot from it since their
narratives are so in in contrast I think
that information needs to be shared with
us and shared with us soon there's a lot
of pressure there's a lot of pressure
for the u.s. to react how long can
investigation like this go on for that's
a that's a great question as the
information flows in the analysts will
start to make judgments but along with
that judgment will be a confidence level
so they could start out by saying you
know we believe the Saudis killed him
inside the consulate but we only have
low confidence in that and over a period
of a week to two weeks that confidence
level could rise so there's really two
pieces the judgment and the confidence
level and I would say once the analysts
have the information it could be 7 10 14
days before they come down with a firm
conclusion you know the president seemed
very reluctant Mike to end the business
deal the arms business deal with Saudi
Arabia if this is true is there any way
that we should still do business with
Saudi Arabia he pointed out it's an
awful lot of money Gail I think there's
a there's there's sort of three
different buckets of things the United
States could do if indeed the Saudis
were involved in his disappearance in
his death one at the low end of the
spectrum would be limited sanctions
against those individuals and those
entities who were specifically involved
in the murder in the middle would be a
delay in arm sales and at the far end
would be sort of broad sanctions against
Saudi Arabia in general my guess would
be that we would send that we would end
up somewhere in with with a mix of the
lower end in the middle end I think if
the Saudis were involved in this you
will see some delay in arms sales
despite what the president says all
right Michael Morell always good to see
you thank you very much
welcome